- [Voiceover] So this is Sal Khan here
with Emily Abrash, our
Biology Content Fellow.
And you have a PhD in Biology,
so you know what you're talking about.
- [Voiceover] You'd like to
think that, wouldn't you.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] And so, Khan Academy has had
biology content for a long time now.
You know, back in the
day, I think in 2007, 2008
I had made a handful of biology videos.
But what are we hoping to do now?
- [Voiceover] I mean, I
think here what we're really
going for is having really
comprehensive coverage.
Really making sure that
we look at all of the
different branches of biology
and have great material
that's going to be a resource
for someone who's looking
at any one of those.
You know, not just certain
things that happen to be cool,
but really digging into a
lot of different branches
of this subject.
- [Voiceover] And so how
are you thinking about it.
I mean, you're out there,
trying to figure out
what we should cover and
what we shouldn't cover.
What is your hope for the next year?
- [Voiceover] My hope is
really that we're going to have
material that will serve
pretty much anybody
who's in, like, an
advanced high school level
or an intro college level class.
And I mean, there's a lot of
diversity in those classes,
so it's not going to match every class.
But the hope would be that
if you encounter a topic
that you're confused
about or interested in
in one of those classes,
that you'd be able to come to us
and really learn more about that.
- [Voiceover] And the way
we've been working together
is fun, it's fun to have
people to work with now.
(laughter)
They never fit into the walk-in
closet, but now we have...
And you know, you've been
doing a pretty incredible job.
You've been obviously
taking a high level view,
thinking about the different
gaps, what we need to fill in,
to really have exhaustive coverage for
intro college biology class,
or an AP biology class.
You've been writing articles
like this one right over here,
where you really get a hopefully
intuitive but thoughtful
explanation and kind of deep explanation
of what's going on.
We're also working together
to produce more videos
so that, once again, we don't just cover
a lot of the main ideas in biology,
we're covering all of the
things that you would see
in an AP biology class or a college class.
So, what's next? What are
you working on right now?
- [Voiceover] Right now I am just sort of
in the middle of genetics.
You've already got a lot of
great videos on genetics,
so I'm kind of looking
at what we already have,
as well as sort of some
extensions of that.
Like the sort of chromosomal
basis of genetics
and how that was discovered.
So that's kind of what's
on my plate right now,
but after that, it will
kind of be full steam ahead
into molecular biology, DNA replication,
transcription and translation.
Which again, we've already
got some great content on,
but there are places
where I think we can even
build it out some more.
- [Voiceover] I'm excited,
I know I have a backlog
of four or five videos
that you've been asking for
for a few days, so they'll be coming soon.
- [Voiceover] I'm excited for them!
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Thank you.